(Kristina laughs)
- [Mark] All right, Kristina.
Kristina, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from?
- [Kristina] Riverside.
- [Mark] Riverside, California.
And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents?
- Nah, I wasn't...
My mom used to smoke crack,
but she still does actually.
She's still around here.
She gave me to the system when
I was like two months old.
I got adopted.
And my adopted family decided
to give me up as well.
And so I was really just jumping around,
foster home to foster home,
like throughout my life.
- [Mark] So how was your childhood?
Sounds pretty rough.
- Didn't really have one honestly.
I had to grow up too fast.
My mom didn't have any money
for the bills, nothing.
So it was like,
I would go out sell drugs,
do some bullshit.
Started gang banging,
do some more dumb shit.
Getting caught up for dumb
shit I didn't even do.
- [Mark] What age were you on the streets?
- 12.
- [Mark] 12.
You joined a gang?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Which gang?
- MS.
- [Mark] It's MS-13?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Mexican gang?
- No, Salvadorian gang.
- [Mark] From Salvador (mumbles).
- They have a really like sick
ass reputation (chuckles).
- [Mark] And are you using drugs?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Which drug?
- Meth.
- [Mark] How long have you used that?
- Since I was 12 (chuckles).
- [Mark] And you're working
as a prostitute as well?
- Once in a while.
- [Mark] How often do you do that?
- Whenever the money's good.
- [Mark] How old are you now?
- 16.
- [Mark] You're 16?
Are you going to high school?
- No.
- [Mark] Why'd you drop out?
- I never made it (chuckles).
- [Mark] What grade did you finish?
- Eighth.
- [Mark] And instead of going
to school you just been...
What do you do for money now?
- Sell drugs and prostitute, I guess.
- [Mark] Do you have any
contact with your family?
- No.
They don't talk to me.
Don't speak with me at all.
- [Mark] You've been arrested?
(Kristina mumbles)
- [Mark] What kind of
stuff did get you arrested?
- In (mumbles),
fucking...
Breaking and entering...
Breaking into private property,
stuff like that.
Assault.
Assault with a deadly weapon.
Though shit...
I feel that I have a wire (laughs).
- [Mark] You kind of do.
(Kristina laughs)
The whole world including the police
are gonna listen to this.
- Oh God.
(Mark laughs)
Oh, that's great. Fuck yeah.
- [Mark] So where do you see
your life going from here?
You're 16.
- I'm probably gonna be dead.
- [Mark] How would you die
most likely do you think?
What's the most dangerous,
most likely way that you would die?
- My hood.
- [Mark] Just the gang violence
and the guns and all that?
- It's my hood or
my pimp.
- [Mark] You have a pimp?
- Something like that.
- [Mark] He keeps your money?
- No. I wish he would.
Yeah, it's pretty fucked up.
You know, everybody out here knows me.
- [Mark] Where do you live now?
- Everywhere.
- [Mark] But do you have like...
Are you homeless?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] You are?
So you stay on the street in
Skid Row or somewhere else?
- Everywhere.
- [Mark] Just wherever?
- Wherever the money is at.
- [Mark] But what neighborhood
do you normally hang out,
in East LA somewhere?
- Yeah.
You know,
everybody out here sees me and,
people think I'm fine.
People don't know what
people like me go through.
Kind of sucks.
- [Mark] What do you think
people don't understand?
- The struggle.
It's hard to be out here by yourself
with nobody to trust, nobody to go to.
- [Mark] No family.
- I've called my parents a million times
trying to beg 'em to go home (mumbles).
Nobody cares about nobody here.
Out here it's all doggy dog world.
People think that when
they have a job and shit
that they have it good, you know.
They think that they
are fucking struggling,
that they're fucking going
through it or whatever.
They're not going through shit.
They don't know what it's like
to fucking eat out of the trash
or to fucking
not have,
fucking clothes to wear
or shoes that fit you.
They don't know what it's like
to be afraid for tomorrow.
to do something that you don't
want to do just to survive.
This is the shit that I go
through on a daily basis.
- [Mark] What's the
worst thing you've seen
when out here?
- I have seen my best
friend get her hair cut off.
- [Mark] For what?
- Because she didn't want to pay up.
I seen them bringing
girls younger than me.
Like just fuck 'em up, like bad.
(mumbles) just killed.
No one's ever gonna know where they're at,
what they did, nothing.
- [Mark] These are gang related incidents
or
- No. Street.
- [Mark] Just street stuff?
What about your childhood
could have been different?
It might have spared
you from this situation?
- Maybe if my family would
have actually given a fuck
a little bit more,
and maybe I would have been different.
- [Mark] Was your dad ever in the picture?
- [Kristina] Yeah, but
my dad was a fucking...
(Kristina mumbles)
- [Mark] Was he ever in your life?
- For sure, awhile.
- [Mark] What would you say to your dad
if you could speak to him?
- [Kristina] Fuck you.
"Fuck you" 'cause he was the
one that made me this way.
- [Mark] Do you have any
dreams or goals or anything
you'd like to see happen in your future?
You're still very young.
- [Kristina] I want to just be happy, bro.
The only dream I probably
got is just to be happy.
'Cause just because I smile every day,
just because I walk around like I'm cool,
I'm not happy.
(mumbles) look at myself in the
mirror without feeling like,
"Damn, this is what life is."
- [Mark] You get depressed a lot?
- [Kristina] Yeah, but I don't show it.
Because if you show it,
then it's a sign of weakness
and when you're weak
is when the people prey on you most.
I just learned how to
make sure that everyone thinks I'm cool.
- [Mark] You have close friends?
- [Kristina] Nah, they
ain't no friends out here.
Sometimes when I look around
all I see is animals worse
than animals actually, maggots,
'cause animals don't even do what we do.
Sometimes you'll find
yourself in a relationship
where the only reason
you're sticking around
is because that nigga gives
you food or a place to stay.
But he'll beat the fuck
out of you every day.
But, shit,
he's feeding you, he's clothing you,
giving you somewhere to stay.
If you leave you'd be ungrateful.
- [Mark] What would help
you the most right now?
- Escape.
Sometimes I wish I could just
pack my shit and run away.
Run away to where?
Everywhere I go is the same thing.
No one's ever gonna be able to understand
the trials and tribulations
that come with being on the streets.
The streets will take
your soul, eat it up.
And you'll never be able to get away.
It's crazy 'cause it's like,
people think that just because
I'm young and I'm a girl
and I'm pretty supposedly,
that they can just
take advantage of whatever
the fuck it is that I have.
Nobody ever really knows
what's up with anything.
I used to be a cutter, bro.
See, when I was younger.
And then one day I was in MacArthur Park,
and there was these dudes
that wanted to fuck.
I told 'em, "Nah, I'm cool."
I woke up at three in the morning with,
I was laying on my stomach and
one of them was on top of me
on my back.
They had sliced my neck open, bro.
They sliced my shit open.
- [Mark] Oh, wow.
It's a bad scar.
They cut it with wire, right?
- A machete.
And then they all ran.
You know,
these streets will take
something beautiful
and they'll just like crush it
and just like make sure that
that's nothing (mumbles).
Because out here there's just one thing.
Money talks, bullshit walks.
You could pay somebody to
do anything out here, bro,
and they'll do it.
If it's the price is right.
I got kidnapped from Riverside.
I got kidnapped, I got taken over here.
I saw my best friend get her hair cut off,
and I ran.
She died basically so I could run,
me and some other girl.
I ended up over there in Legion Park.
Then
I went to Olvera Street
and started selling dope,
smoking dope.
I met this guy named Chaka, my baby's dad.
He used to make me prostitute myself
or else I was dead.
He told me basically like
"If you don't sell your
pussy, I'ma kill you."
And so for a long time I was doing that
with the fear of if I don't
do this, I'm gonna die.
And then one day I just had to run away.
When I ran away, I just never went back.
After that I started getting
to fucked up relationships,
abusive relationships.
And every time I would meet somebody
that I thought was gonna help,
they just ended up fucking me over.
When I had my daughter,
I thought my family was
going to let me go back home.
I called my mom and I told her like,
"mom,
"like I had a baby.
"Can I please go back home.
"I don't want to be out here."
She told me, "(mumbles)
like a personal problem."
She hung up on me.
So everything I ever thought was right,
isn't really right out here, it's wrong.
Whatever I thought was wrong is right.
What is, isn't, what isn't is.
I seen children,
old people,
get killed just 'cause
they don't want to comply
with what the fuck these people want.
I've been raped so many times
I can't even count on one hand.
My grandmother died I
couldn't go to her funeral.
My father died I couldn't
go to his funeral.
And yet I still find a
reason to smile every day.
I've been kidnapped before at gunpoint.
I've been robbed.
I've been stabbed, all that shit.
Sucks.
'Cause nobody will ever know
what a person like me goes
through on a daily basis
or give a fuck really, honestly.
I go to the store I see
people that have a life,
they have somewhere to
go, have somewhere to be.
They look at me with disgust
and I just think to myself like,
"Damn, I wonder how they would look at me
"if they knew what I've been through."
And the only reason I'm
doing this because I hope
that maybe somebody who
gives a fuck will listen.
And somebody who gives a
fuck would try and help.
That's what I'm hoping for.
- [Mark] Kristina, thank you
so much for talking with me.
- Don't even trip.
Gotcha.